[Music]  jim gordon never gave up on anything  that's why gotham city is still here  it's why i'm still here  and i've known for a while now that  someday like him  i'd have to work with you  i've seen plenty of criminals in my  career but  nothing could have prepared me for this  [Music]  well well if it isn't brat girl  gotham city is at her weakest  there's blood in the water  and the sharks are circling  they're all making their moves  play nice  but we aren't going to give up  a storm has risen over gotham  nothing can  i need your help  your skills  your knowledge  your adaptability  you got my back  the world will feel the cold as i do  i got one last little surprise for you  come to watch the show redwood  i'm just here to kick your ass  pre-order now and get the 233 custom bat  cycle skin